et la crise craignent haine qui sera
également au coeur des échanges entre
viktor orban et vladimir poutine le
premier ministre hongrois est en visite
aujourd'hui à moscou et il sera aussi
question de livraisons de gaz russe en
hongrie alors que les prix de l'énergie
flambe en europe plus d'informations
avec notre correspondante à moscou
maylis des strings moscou et budapest
par le rond or bleu aujourd'hui victor
ban a d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il
comptait sur sa rencontre avec vladimir
poutine pour obtenir de la russie une
augmentation des volumes de gaz exporté
en hongrie un objectif particulièrement
important pour budapest compte tenu de
la flambée des prix de l'énergie en
europe la sécurité sur le vieux
continent sera également abordée par les
deux dirigeants dans le contexte des
tensions russo occidentale au sujet de
l'ukraine la visite de viktor orban à
moscou est d'ailleurs vertement critiqué
par l'opposition hongroise d'après
celle-ci en rencontrant vladimir poutine
le premier ministre envoie le signal
d'une désunion entre les états membres
de l'union européenne et de l'otan pour
sa part le kremlin se dit ravi de cette
visite est de l'état de ses relations
avec budapest
[Musique]
c'est une visite très importante
nous avons des relations très
approfondies avec la hongrie nous
apprécions beaucoup l'attitude
indépendante de la hongrie quant à la
satisfaction de ses intérêts propres et
au choix de ses partenaires nous
apprécions beaucoup cela
et nous apprécions également le fait que
malgré toutes les tendances négatives
liées aux coronavirus nous sommes
parvenus à poursuivre tous nos projets
économiques nombreux à l'ordre du jour
il y aura aussi une discussion sur les
questions internationales y compris les
plus d'actualité elles sont bien connues
d'après la diplomatie hongroise l'année
2021 été la plus productive dans
l'histoire de la coopération entre
moscou et budapest
parmi les projets bilatéraux qui devrait
également être abordée lors de la
rencontre d'aujourd'hui la construction
de deux nouveaux réacteurs de la
centrale nucléaire magar pacs ainsi que
l'envoi d'un astronaute hongrois sur la
station spatiale internationale cela